hello everyone and welcome to today's
video where we are diving deep into the
world of networking ever wondered how
devices communicate in the vast Realm of
the internet well we're going to explore
the nitty-gritty details we will start
with the IP address blocks and what's
called subnetting just ways to organize
stuff in the digital world curious about
subnets and subnet masks stick around we
have got the simple scoop the star of
the show is the subnet mask a sort of
secret code that helps break down IP
addresses
after that we will cover different types
of IP addresses and then the benefits of
submitting and before commencing just a
quick info for you if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for an online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
the leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security from the MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work R
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen of others so if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comments and the
description box so let's start with the
first topic so how do IP addresses work
IP V4 address such as 172 31.
45.6 may seem like regular numbers but
they are actually just a way of
representing binary information imagine
breaking down each address into four
parts or blocks and each of these blocks
is made up of eight bits which are like
tiny switches that can either be on or
off one or zero since there are eight
bits in each block we call them octets
and because there are four of these
octets in an ipv4 address the total bits
for the entire address is 32 bits so
when you see an IP address like 17 2.3
1.4
45.6 each of these four parts is
actually a group of eight switches in
the on and off position making up for
total of 32 bits this binary
representation is a way for computers to
communicate and understand these
addresses on the internet to understand
this we will have a look at the chart
let's consider the process of converting
the IP address 172.2 0.3 0.40 into
binary all right now simply divide the
address into four blocks 172 20 30 and
40 and transform each block into binary
adhering to Binary conversion chart it
essential to note that in binary one
represents on while 0er represents of to
convert the first block 172 into binary
begin at the charts beginning and assign
ones or zeros to the corresponding cells
until their sum equals to 172 repeat
this process for each block in the IP
address for like 20 also for 30 also and
for 40
also all right now moving on to the next
topic which is
subnetting so what is subnetting
subnetting is a strategic process of
dividing a network into smaller subn
networks or subnets with the goal of
enhancing efficiency security and overal
performance the primary advantage lies
in alloying devices within a subnet to
communicate directly eliminating the
need to Traverse unnecessary routers
Beyond this subnetting AIDS in
organizing the network structure and
elevating traffic
congestion in the process of subnetting
certain bits from the host part of an IP
address are allocated to signify the
subnet leading to adjustments in the
subnet mask the subnet mask presented as
binary number delineates which bits on
the IP address belongs to the network
and which pertain to the host for for
instance a subnet mask of
255.255.255.0 indicates that the initial
24 bits of the IP address represent the
network while remaining eight bits
represents the host so this was about
subnetting now let's understand the
difference between subnets and subnet
masks the distinction between subnets
and the subnet mask is crucial to
understanding Network architecture while
subnet mask plays a pivotal role in the
concept of subnets they distinct
entities a subnet short for sub Network
refers to specific segment of the
network this segment shares the overall
Network's IP address but possesses a
unique subnet address essentially a
subnet allows for The Logical division
of a larger Network into smaller more
meaningful units on the other hand a
subnet mask serves a different purpose
it is numerical value that distinguishes
between the part of an IP address
corresponding to the subnet and the part
that identifies the host with in the
subnet so now let's understand what is
subnet mask so a subnet mask is like a
guide that helps computers understand
the different parts of an IP address
picture an IP address as a location
where the network is the street name and
the host is the house number for example
consider the IP address
192.168.1 23.13 2 in this case the first
three sets of IP address 1
192.168.1 123 show the Network while the
last set specifies a particular device
on that Network to make it simpler we
use a DOT decimal system for IP
addresses breaking down the 32 binary
bits that is four sets of eight bits
into more manageable groups so the
subnet mask act as a kind of decoder
helping computers figured out which part
of IP address is the network and which
part identifies the specific device it
makes Communication in networks Easier
by organizing these addresses in a way
that devices can understand now let's
have a look at its working all right so
how do subnet masks work so subnet mask
is a 32-bit numerical value that divides
an IP address into distinct Network and
host address as we know now in the
subnet mask the network part is
represented by all ones while the host
part consist of all zeros for instance a
subnet mask like
255.255.255.0 indicates that initial 24
bits pertain to the networ leaving the 8
bit for the host this subnet mask
facilitates communication among devices
within a subnet which functions as a
smaller Network within a larger Network
subnetting achieved through subnet mask
minimizing the broadcast traffic
enhancing overall Network efficiency and
Security to apply a subnet mask to an IP
address a bitwise and operation between
the two numbers is performed for example
if the IP address is
192.168.1 100 and the subnet mask is
255.255.255.0 the resulting Network
address is
192.168.1.0 this signifies that the
device is a part of subnet
192.168.1 024 where the sl24 denotes the
number of bits allocated to the network
part all right so this was about the
working of subnet mask now let's
understand different types of IP
addresses all right so first of all we
have is Class A which lies between
1.0.0 to
126.0 point0 so reserved these class is
reserved for large networks it allows
for up to 126 networks with each Network
having almost 17 million unique host
addresses all right then we have his
class B it range is 128.0 z.0 to 191
255.0.0.0
for mediumsized networks it permits
around 16,000 networks with each Network
supporting nearly 65,000 unique host
addresses all right now coming to class
C so Class C ranges from
1920. to
22325 5.25 5.0 commonly used for smaller
networks with approximately 2 million
available networks each class c network
can accommodate up to 254 unique host
addresses
then class D
224.000 to 23925 5255
255 so this is the range of Class D
reserved for multicast groups this class
is not assigned for individual networks
but is used for group communication
devices that join a multic class group
share information after that class E it
ranges from
24.0 to
255.255 255 to 255 reserved for for
purposes not intended for General use on
public networks Class E address are set
aside for testing and
development so these were the different
types of IP addresses you can have a
look at them now let's understand the
benefits of subnet masks first is
enhanced security so it bolsters defense
mechanisms to protect against potential
threats ensuring the safety of data and
Communications then there is smooth data
flow it is the second benefit it
promotes smoother data flow preventing
slowdowns and interruptions resulting in
more efficient Network all right then
improve Network performance it enhances
the speed and reliability of connections
optimizing the overall user experience
less Network congestion streamlines the
network minimizing delays and improving
overall productivity next is improve
Network performance it enhances the
speed and reliability of connections
optimizing the overall user experience
then at last we have is less Network
congestion it streamlines the network
and minimizing delays and improving
overall productivity all right so these
were the benefits of subnetting so as we
conclude our exploration into subnetting
and IP addresses we have covered the
basics from how IP address blocks
operate to the Ines of subnetting and
the role of subnet masks understanding
the different types of IP addresses and
the perks of subnetting adds depth to
our knowledge implementing subnetting
not only enhances security but also
improves overall Network efficiency if
you find this video insightful drop your
questions or suggestions in the comment
section below make sure to like this
video and drop down your comments
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domain
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here